to Florida right did you watch the game
I did not watch the game did you watch
it no I was sleeping
hitting ready to stay out real late
tonight ah welcome again to CBS this
morning you know yes celebrations are
already starting around the world in
fact it's already 20/20 in New Zealand
you are looking at midnight celebrations
in Auckland they kicked off just about
an hour ago but we begin with breaking
news and a very different scene in Iraq
violent anti-american protesters are
attacking the US Embassy in Baghdad this
morning guards reportedly have responded
with tear gas and stun grenades Holly
Williamson is in that region following
the story Holly break down for us what's
happening right now good morning well
thousands of protesters moved through
the supposedly high-security Green Zone
in Baghdad this morning an area guarded
by Iraqi security forces and right up to
the perimeter of the u.s. embassy
compound we've seen images that show
them setting fire to the fence pulling
down embassy signs and smashing the
glass of a security box that they also
set on fire there are reports that
teargas canisters being fired and
security cameras being dismantled video
show the protesters chanting god is
great America is the greatest devil and
down with the USA this violent
demonstration is a reaction to American
airstrikes on Sunday targeting a militia
group in Iraq that is backed by Iran
those u.s. strikes killed at least 25
militia fighters the American strikes
were in turn an act of retaliation for
the killing of a US citizen last week an
American contractor working on an Iraqi
military base who died in a rocket
attack there are currently around 5,000
US troops in Iraq and here is the bigger
picture Iran and the u.s. are vying for
influence in Iraq a country that is
fractured and inured to bloodshed nearly
17 years after the US invasion those
tensions are ratcheting up and there are
fears they could turn into a full-blown
proxy war between the u.s. and Iran
fought inside Iraq
adrianna just disturbing pictures Holly
Williams in Turkey thank you and we will
be continuing to follow this developing
story
you